hi there i'm sam hewitt and i'm graham
mctavish
and we're here with buzzfeed today to
find out how well we
actually know each other
[Music]
the first time you met it was in london
in soho i was
uh cast as uh jamie fraser in outlander
and i was auditioning other characters
or other actors
for these parts and in walked mctavish
himself
um sporting what can only be described
as a very
overt outfit that he was wearing it was
sort of pink i think a pink
sweater um some sort of cap
fedora scarf they came in and tried to
take over the space but yeah that's
the first time we met similar memory uh
we met in soho i think it was
it was a very very hot day that probably
explains
the lederhosen that sam was wearing for
the interview
just to just allow his legs to not get
so hot
but thank you your birthday my birthday
i know when that is
again yeah all right
sam's birthday is april the 30th
for a bonus question who's whose
birthday is the day after jamie fraser
boom boom graham's birthday is the
fourth
of january i know the year uh
1700 1771 something like that
something something like late 18th
century yes yeah
middle name sam's middle name is roland
graham's middle name is i think it's
like archibald
no it's um josiah
yosemite elvis it's elvis
it's elvis it's close to l it's james
i think my answer is better than the
real no you should change your name
change your name to graham josiah
elvis your go-to snack
on set graham's go-to snack is whatever
mine is
and he'll just basically take it and eat
it yes and
sam's go-to snack well a bit of a
protein shake
guy i was very jealous of the protein
shake so i insisted in getting one on as
well
their favorite alcoholic drink well
whiskey
for sam yes and for graham uh cold
shabbly correct some sort of white wine
the most expensive
white wine of which he will then charge
not to production not to his room he'll
charge to my room
that's right you didn't know that i
would charge my room to your room
sneaky your first acting job weren't you
burlesque wasn't it burlesque or
something
wasn't it like it's a 1940s show
if it wasn't that i'm imagining it's
theater and you probably played the dame
in a pantomime yes it was theater it was
actually a play by samuel beckett called
crap's last tape
did you play crap uh i was crap now what
was your first job your first job
i think children's entertainer wasn't it
something like that juggling for
children
oh you mean like the puppet like one of
those welcome to uh
exactly no i think it wasn't actually no
oh it was also a play
called outlying islands and it was in my
second year at drama school and i got
passed
all night that was your first job their
favorite scene moment you've filmed
together
i think culloden we explore the battle
of cologne in the in the last episode of
melanchol i think
that for you is possibly your favorite
that's definitely in the top five
i would say your favorite scene was
watching me um
abseil off the side of a cliff yeah it's
true
favorite place for you to visit in
scotland your favorite place
would be anything above 3000 feet
ah yes that's good so it'll be in monroe
yes indeed your favorite place to visit
in scotland i know you love the islands
benbecula i know you love applecross
you know cycling your bicycle but i'm
gonna say your favorite place
is a restaurant in edinburgh it
generally anywhere where graham can eat
and drink you're correct about the
cycling anywhere that i'm cycling around
scotland i'm very happy but
eating is very important their all-time
favorite movie or tv show
graham's favorite movie tv show it's
going to be
monty python ah yeah yeah
it's toxically influential yeah your one
favorite movie or tv show oh dear
i'll give you a clue there's two people
in it one is extremely
handsome and brave the other one is a
bit of a buffoon
they experience different parts of
wherever they go
the young one who's much younger
compared to the buffoon
compared to the buffoon he's just great
an all-time around sort of great kind of
guy
i think you're uh possibly referring to
the show we made together but there are
certain
things that you mentioned that i don't
recognize ah
eight out of nine you know absolutely
everything
i know everything about you you've been
in each other's lives for quite some
time
and now you've got very close while
filming you are basically
the same person this is terrifying once
you sit on the back of a tender bicycle
behind graham mctavish
there's not really much else to to know
about him because yeah
the idea that we've basically become the
same person is so disturbing on so many
levels
can i have some of your money then or
your house
men in kilts is on stars and the stars
app
by graham
you